الثقوب السوداء هي بعض الاشكال الاكثر
غموضا وغرابه في الفضاء يقول العلماء انهم
عثروا على ادله جديده تشير الى احتمال
اندماج ثقبين اسودين ظاهره يعتبرها البعض
غير مسبوقه في عالم الفيزياء وتقول وكاله
ناسا ان اثنين من التلسكوبات الفضائيه
التابعه لها وجدا معلومات جديده عن اشاره
ضوئيه غريبه متكرره بشكل نمطي قادمه من
وسط مجره بعيده في كوكبه العذراء التي
تبعد حوالي ث مليار سنه ضوئيه ونصف عن
الارض وفقا للباحثين فان المعلومات
الجديده هي افضل دليل حتى الان على ان
الاشارات الضوئيه القادمه من الثقبين
الاسودين الهائلين يدوران معا اقرب من اي
اثنين اكتشفها حتى الان استطاع العلماء ان
يتتبع تغير انماط حركه الضوء على مدى
السنوات العشرين الماضيه ومن المتوقع ان
يصطدم الثقب ويندمج في اقل من مليون سنه
مما قد يؤدي الى انفجار ضخم ولكن لماذا كل
هذا الاهتمام في الثقوب السوداء المدمجه
الجزء الاكبر من الاهتمام هو لان الثقوب
السوداء تعتبر لغزا كبيرا اذ يعتقد
العلماء ان هناك مليارات منها في الكون
كما يقول الخبراء انهم يمكنهم تحديد
الغازات وغيرها من الاشياء التي تنجر الى
الثقوب السوداء في اللحظات الاخيره قبل
اصطدامها من المتوقع ان تسبب الثقوب
السوداء تموجات في الفضاء والوقت تدعى
باسم موجات الجاذبيه والتي قد تحمل ادله
حول نسيج الكون وفقا للعلماء
un